mr dwyer were you aware
of funds for tennis court that ms knope
requested
that was denied by mr ron swanson that
was later approved
by ben wyatt no do you play tennis
i don't know are you aware of what
tennis is
yeah what point comes after deuce
wipe
sometimes when i wipe i'll wipe
and i'll wipe and i'll wipe and i'll
wipe
a hundred times still poop still poop
let me check that it's like i'm wiping a
marker or something
just to be safe find out who it is and
silence him with pleasure
no don't kill him just make sure he
can't talk anymore
understood what
coming soon to dvd and not blu-ray nab
woke up and it's a day unlike any other
because today
is the day when the rest of his life
actually begins
official submission for the pawnee film
festival
he feels trapped by his life from the
twisted mind of visionary writer
producer director ben wyatt
the detail is rich i think as a
filmmaker it's important to get the
details right the special extended
director's cut
double the original running time i could
not be prouder of this
requiem for a tuesday get up and face a
brand new
day now you'll never look at clay maish
the same way again and now back to more
parks and recreation
i dare you i double dog dario
give me a reason bro give me a reason to
take you down
i would
i want three minutes with her alone
three minutes
i think we'd all appreciate it we
i think the toilets and i would okay
i tell you what i would like what i'm
gonna ask you for
can you hold it together yeah i'm sorry
shut up okay so many
stickers so so few good books
[Laughter]
that is fantastic looking oh god she's
coming for me
help me leslie help oh god how you been
really good thank you nice to see you
ma'am good to see you too
nice to see you mother oh my god mother
what's happening
john ralphio
oh my god no
hey jennifer look what we can do
jennifer jennifer
jeff jennifer look what we're look what
we're doing
oh really
jennifer he's actually in me
i got it i got it nice oh yeah
i also got some dude's briefcase
i believed in you buddy but you should
put that back
yeah how did you get this
well what that is
[ __ ] hilarious you shattered the
lights you shattered it not only did you
hit the wall
heads around it that's not something
that props can fix
that's gonna be a little harder to pick
some [ __ ] sorry
i'm out
up next is my introduction to the next
segment and my introduction is as
follows
here's the next segment that concludes
my introduction
are you looking to improve the quality
of your life well the solution may be
right in front of you
pawnee community college sign up by
april 1st to enroll in summer courses
pawnee community college achieving
standards
every day and now back to more parks and
recreation
thank you to everybody season four rap
on everybody
[Music]
catch your dreams
[Music]
catch your dreams
[Music]
just got one
calculator
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that dream is won't go down easy
it's gonna struggle to break free me
until we beat it since there's the
courage
hope and will yes we will
we gonna
[Music]
cause is not enough
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to your heart
everyone loves a good comeback story
right seabiscuit
the mighty ducks robert downey jr
rocky yes kim kardashian kim well
wow in the video she gets she gets come
on her back i think
party
you